I don't want to all right
another oculus rift horror I'm not a big
fan of these mainly because it's [ __ ]
terrifying inside this thing I'm doing
it for your brother my ship is [ __ ]
got it run oh god I have to run jump
with f
what's wrong with jumping with space if
you enjoy the game
well I doubt it sir generating new map
oh it's a procedurally generated so this
is like Slenderman in spas am i throwing
my balls on it cuz I'm out of balls then
oh good thing I had three thank you both
you've done a great purpose I hope I
didn't need you to survive or some [ __ ]
like that
oh god are we on the lowest floor Oh
always time for more balls that's what
she said Oh oh god there's blood already
Oh oh god oh god ah alright so this is
the map I have no [ __ ] clue how to
read that oh god we're going down down
and Funkytown yay oh god I'm breathing
no no what was that No okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna here okay there is a
map I don't know how to [ __ ] read it
okay swear to God I hear something do
you need my balls yes
gods [ __ ] it's eating my balls what is
down there oh god oh god no I love life
no no no okay the map it's not helping
hello
be nice to me please I have great
feelings that doesn't need you to be a
[ __ ] about it thank you
now what the [ __ ] was point with that
door some of these doors are completely
senseless mein I feel like those doors
are gonna chew Oh God blood what is this
what is going on what is going on Oh
I got infected so I can't step on the
blood because I get dead that was easy
find one Oh BOM toe I'm amazing
whoa what is happening there that is
some weird [ __ ] man
okay I think we have to go down here
well besides what does look at that run
oh my god oh my god I'm trapped
I can't do it brass please let me go
monsters cannot be killed in order to
get want to stop chasing you you must
run around corners so that the monster
becomes confusing gives up oh oh oh
wish I knew that [ __ ] that it is alright
got it one amazing oh god I hear him I
gotta hit him oh yeah here don't hurt me
I'm Swedish we don't taste very good I
taste like pie and not the good pie not
like apple pie I play it tastes like oh
god a dead end oh god please don't come
on I'm basically throwing I can walk in
the blood can i oh I can okay we're fine
what the [ __ ] did that guy do run run
what no no no no no no no go go go don't
don't go you [ __ ] out alright I think
we confuse the [ __ ]
it's like a maze and it's not amazing
get it ha
dead-end this son of a [ __ ] I've got
blood that blood was not there before
Wow
right when I need you now you take away
the biggest part of me oh baby please go
home oh it's so dark it's so dark it's
oh don't get so don't get so don't get
so I get the door get the door get the
door get the door get the bag get the
bag back of the guard
please get confused oh god I press shift
too many times oh my god if I die
because I pressed shift too many times
ice oh God
okay alright I'm so lonely
umm poor day lonely I have nobody I'm on
my own
Josh [ __ ] come on come on hurry up it's
getting there k oh yeah I have bulls but
I don't want to use us thank you
four out of seven bitched four out of
seven what you gonna do about my ass
inside your ass are you gonna try to put
it out oh you're gonna try to put it in
girl oh wait what is that
Oh God alright confuse him how do I
confuse a bit when I'm confused maybe
sexually confused I hope it's not well I
don't know to be honest you can do it
can be well god no
this is not my game
[Music]
all right I'm gonna it's a new day it's
a new laughs its new can't see anything
all right let's try this again all right
here we go what yeah yeah what's up Jeff
Lawrence get him Nick done on me
oh my god I got a jump
nailed it let's go here oh my god [ __ ]
me oh that's a lock door that means we
can't go there am i right is that girl
talking shut ah are the Bulls made to
navigate third skater hey potat
maybe there's space potatoes that would
make sense at least
Oh God blood yes much where the [ __ ] am
I don't [ __ ] know I am NOT yo ho
listen to me bro
where the [ __ ] am I there we go
five out of seven [ __ ] five out of
seven what you gonna do in heaven when
I'm dead girl I'm gonna die girl I'm
gonna die rod rod run around the corners
so he gets confused say said what I'm
running all right every [ __ ] I
every truck I tried
every potato skate every nightly mate I
will